Yeah, so how can we make forms that
are fast, easy and accurate to fill in?
Which is essentially all of form design.
So, I'll try a distill
an entire book slash
years worth of materials into
a couple of minute answer.
But at the very highest level,
when we have a series of
questions we need answered.
The process we should start with is this
thing that Caroline Gerrit calls, keep,
cut, postpone, or kill,
I think is the right methodology.
I might have one of those words wrong.
But keep is, this is information
that's critical, required,
we've got to have it
in the form somewhere.
Cut, I guess that's the one for kill.
Cut means we actually don't need it.
And it's surprising how many times
you can go and look at forms and
see things that are included there and
nobody's even actually using.
You go and talk to the team like, oh,
well what are we doing
with this piece of data?
I don't know.
because it's over here, has anybody
look at this in the past three years?
No, but we've always collected this.
So here it is.
So there's stuff you can cut.
Postpone is things
that you can ask later.
So there's a lot of information that
we force you to give us upfront,
which isn't applicable, and
actually has a better time and
place further down in the flow.
So postponing questions
until they're appropriate
is a really good strategy as well,
and the last one is explain.
And explain just basically boils down
to telling people why you're asking for
something, or
how they can answer that question.
There's a case study at the beginning
of my web form design book where
a major e-tailer, a huge e-commerce
site, had two options at checkout,
one was log-in and one was register.
It turned out you could actually
register without creating an account.
You could actually buy something
without making an account, but
it was totally unclear
from that language.
Login or register.
So what they did is they changed the
label of the button that said register
to continue and
they put a little bit of text that said
you do not need an account to continue.
And conversions went
up something like 30%.
They made 300 million
more a year overnight,
just from explaining what they
were actually talking about.
So that keep, cut, postpone, and
explain methodology is great
at the very highest level.
Then when you go deeper, you get much
more into interaction design and
visual design considerations.
What's the right input control for
this type of question?
How do I minimize typing mistakes?
How do I bound people so
that they don't go into an error state?
And you can do that with things
like custom keyboards, input types,
inline validation.
There's a whole school of methodology
for the nuances of forms.
But it all starts at that bigger picture
methodology of really thinking through
what should be there, where and
what you need to tell people about
the questions you're asking them,
if that makes sense.